what if i told you there's a few million
dollars around you that could be yours
but you got to go find it yes
a few million dollars that could be
yours but you got to go find it and no
this is not an infomercial i got nothing
to sell you so let's talk about this
pat you really mean i could have a few
million dollars yes what do you mean by
that let me explain to you years ago i'm
working at ballet total fitness
in chatsworth i'm the manager and one
day
we're not hitting our numbers our guys
are not hitting the numbers and i'm
getting to a point where i'm realizing
these guys are negative but i got to get
them to snap
out of it i said guys come here what's
going on what we can't sell no one wants
to buy a membership
no one wants to come to this club this
club's never sold any membership like
guys i do not want to hear it
but we're going to do an exercise so
what's that take a walk with me in the
club so we go around
i said i want you to count how many
members are working out
right now they say you want me to count
how many members are working i say yes
let's go count
so we walk clicker one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
we had only 100 people that were working
out at the gym we had a second story
a pool weights cardio you know aerobics
we had around 100 people at the gym
right now
i said let me ask you out of these
hundred people here how many of them
know you by your first name
uh she does uh he does
maybe five people i said how come the
other 95 don't know you
i see you ever talked to the other 95 i
said no i said what if i told you if we
were to go to talk to these hundred
people
how many of them would be willing to
entertain a short conversation with us
let's say a third of them that's what 33
of them yes okay what's your point
how many of those 33 that are willing to
talk to us know
someone that could come in today to buy
a membership
today if we treated them well come on
pat what do you mean
come on pat how many of those 33 would
buy a membership today
ah become bad people don't want to be
bothered i said okay
you don't think so let me go dude just
watch me and i started going to
can i can i uh spot you do you need any
help with this
have you looked at this have you ever
thought about doing triceps i'm going to
take what i learned the other day from a
bodybuilder can i give you something
is there anything you need to towel how
long you been working out here all of a
sudden i started talking to a few people
i click with one i click with two i
click with three
three people that they came and bought
bought a membership from me
on friday night three came to my
membership and friday friday night so my
guys are sitting right there they're
like
pat who are these guys i don't have
these guys on the books they're showing
up now why
because i went and used my existing
block of business
which is 100 active members that are
working out today
who love our gym they love our equipment
they have committed to come and you work
out
sweat shower everything they're
committed to this gym
why are we not talking to the community
people in our lives
so i went and talked to a few of them i
somehow made
300 because back to you made around 100
per member should be sold
i said you can't do that well i know i
can do that next thing you know we
became the number one gym and we were
selling
outselling everybody we hit our numbers
by 115 what does this have to do with
you
everything here's why i want you to
think about how many contacts you have
how many contacts do you have total on
your phone how many total phone numbers
you have on your phone okay
how many friends do you have on your
facebook so phone write down the number
you could say 289 great
928 whatever the numbers is here
phenomenal how many instagram friends do
you have
i have 926 great i have 19 000
i have 600 whatever how many facebook
write all of them down okay what do you
do for a living
you do real estate you do loans
you do insurance you do finances
what do you do digital marketing what is
it you do
how many of all of those contacts know
what you do
first question you know what the number
typically is
five to ten percent most of your peers
have no clue what you do
because you haven't told them yet okay
pat so what do you mean by that do i
sell all these people
they're not people that would want to
buy my product i never said you go sell
them
i say you go talk to them and you ask
how you can help them
then you ask them the following question
this is the magical question that can
make you a lot of money
and introduce you to anybody you want
this one magical question you ready
who do you know that dot
dot dot dot dot how do you unpack that
question anything who do you know
that is single with no kids under the
age of 25
who is somebody that's a family person
church going
that's willing to date somebody today
nobody great
but if i send it to 100 people one of my
friends and family may say
i have a friend i'd like to introduce
you to who do you know that is
single not married no kids
college degree he's making he's got a
good career he's hard working he's from
a good family who do you know
and people say i know six people to
introduce you to here's another question
who do you know that's currently living
in a house that's got a half a million
dollar loan
that's professional that's got a good
courier going but they would like to
refinance their house
and want to save some money who do you
know who do you know who do you know and
then add whatever you want to add next
to it right okay
i i started my market everything i've
done insurance
stocks as a stock broker as a business
owner in
every as a content creator wanting to
find interviews at the beginning when we
had 150 subscribers
and nobody wanted to talk to us we had
150 subscribers
everything was who do you know who do
you know who do you know
and at the beginning rejection rate is
high however
eventually when you ask enough who do
you knows enough people say i know
someone for you
i know someone for you i know someone
for you so remember how i told you
earlier you're sitting on a few million
dollars that could be your money well
pat what if i'm not in sales what do you
mean what if you're not in sales yeah
what if i'm not in sales
okay no problem what if i told you you
know somebody around you right now
that's starting a business that could
potentially have somebody like you help
them
work with them earn respect get some
equity and it can potentially
be part of a start-up phase when the
company has an exit or goes public
they may have 1.2 million dollars of
equity money that could be yours who do
you know
this is not about selling this is not
just about selling this is clientele
this is a significant other this is to
be part of a startup company
this is to be part of a company that's
running on what if you said who do you
know who's the hungriest person you know
that you would follow
hey mom who's the hungriest person you
know that you would work for who asked
questions like that well you
who's the hungriest person you know the
most ambitious person you know that you
trust
that you'd be willing to have someone
like me a friend to go work for
oh if you can work with johnny whoever
it is you're going places
can i get the name what if you send that
message to 500 people
what if you send a message to 500 people
only 50 people respond half of them say
no one the other 25 give you 25 names
you got 25 names now to reach out to
high references
what if you contacted those people i
asked my uncle
who he felt was the most ambitious
person he knew
who was going places who he would trust
for us for somebody like me to work for
who that person would be i said i want
to work for somebody like that he said
you
what do i need to do to get an interview
with you you send that to 25 of those
guys
half of them say i'm not hiring right
now the other half say they're willing
to meet with you for an interview
maybe you go sit with their assistant or
their office manager that interviews you
you impress them then you go sit with
them then you get two offers now you
work with one of them
now they grow the company you become a
voice you get a piece of equity you get
a 1.25 million dollar check
seven years from now you know when that
happens all the time
you know why because somebody at one
point knew how to ask what question
who do you know so we have a couple
exercises today with you number one
take out your phone book and make a list
of how many of those numbers
know exactly what you do number two pull
out your instagram
and go through all your real people that
follow you because you have a
relationship with them not because
you're trying to slide
you know into someone's dm you actually
have a relationship with them
make that list number three who do you
have on your facebook list that's people
that you know you have a relationship
with
how many of them know what course you
need to ask them go ask them
and see what happens you will be
surprised by the kind of results
you can get from this if you do it and
by the way there is no limit on how many
texts you could send out
you can send 500 text messages and see
what kind of response you get
expect to be having your rejection rate
be very high
but if you go with the big numbers
expect to be surprised with the kind of
customers
and opportunities that could come your
way and by the way if you want to know
the formal you know how to make a
million dollar your income the formula
on how to make a million dollar
income i did a video on that a couple
years ago if you've never watched it
click over here to watch that
and if you've not subscribed to the
channel please do so have a great week
everybody
take care
you